[Musique]
le vrai défi au niveau de l'afrique
c'est justement de capitaliser les
connaissances qu'ils ont est aussi et
d'élargir le maximum possible
reconnaissance dans tout ce qui se passe
dans le monde et d'en faire la synthèse
[Musique]
c'est une grosse opportunité
j'aimerais c'est que ce trophée à
étendre les motivations tous les
danseurs
c'est mon pays et tous les danseuses
afrique en particulier du monde en
général
au delà du plie à détourner donc on va
aller faire des tournées on va
rencontrer des gens là bas aussi qu'ils
vont vouloir que je continue à présenter
le projet le départ
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]